[Musique]
il y a deux journées portes ouvertes
pour le pôle formation il y en a une ce
samedi donc le 27 janvier et il y en
aura une deuxième un autre samedi qui
sera le 9 mars
[Musique]
2024 l'idée c'est vraiment d'accueillir
les futurs apprentis et stagiaires de la
formation continue qui viendront dans
nos formations plus tard et de leur à la
fois de leur donner des informations
collectives en particulier sur
l'apprentissage puisqu'on a la
particularité d'être un centre
d'apprentissage ou sur les financements
des formations pour les adultes par
[Musique]
exemple beaucoup de formations épiques
donc lié au métier du cheval que ce soit
l'enseignement ou la gestion de
structures épique on a des formations
liées à l'agriculture bien entendu hein
puisqu'on est un établissement
d'enseignement agricole avec en
particulier des BTS production animale
mal et gestion et stratégie de
l'exploitation agricole et ça c'est très
important parce que dans les années à
venir il va y avoir un fort fort
renouvellement des générations
[Musique]
d'agriculteurs alors c'est un
établissement très singulier hein
d'abord parce que au niveau historique
c'est quand même des des conditions
d'accueil dans un dans un milieu
remarquable que ce soit les bâtiments le
parc c'est comme tout l'enseignement
agricole on a la particularité de
proposer des inter donc 75 % de nos
apprenants sont internes des 400
apprenants de de du centre de formation
sont
internes